my name's Piniella folk I'm a chief
advisor on Africa issue in the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs of Denmark I shows
the subject was the subject of
intergenerational dialogue I think
Africa is characterized by a very very
young population in parallel the typical
African heads of state or government is
quite old and I think this creates
potential tension also considering that
some of the more serious challenges of
Africa's facing relates to some
longer-term issues like climate change
so I think it's very important to engage
young people in a very constructive way
to get their views on how to solve these
challenges